roughly 50% of all the new cases are
taking place in four states and so as
you would anticipate where we are
working with governors and state health
officials in all the states that are
impacted but we're particularly focusing
on the four states that are generating
the majority of the cases which of
course are California Arizona Texas and
Florida I'm pleased to say that while
there are 29 states that have don't have
a combination of rising positivity and
rising cases we also have an additional
ten states that are either entirely
stable or have numbers that are so low
that their de minimis so our focus
particularly at the taskforce today was
on the 12 states that have the
combination beyond that while one life
lost is too many and we mourn the loss
of every American and grieve with every
family that lost a loved one because of
the dedication of our health care
workers because of our response and the
response of the American people we are
grateful that today fatalities are at
the lowest level since the end of March
we continue to be vigilant as we see
rising cases we understand that that
could that could change but again to see
the the precipitous decline in
fatalities is a tribute to the health
care workers in this country and to the
cooperation and the compassion of the
American people our message to every
American in the in the states that are
most affected by rising cases in rising
positivity rates is we are with you we
are working with the governors in your
state to ensure that they have the
resources and the support to meet this
moment and provide the level of health
care that any one of us would would
expect for a member of our families but
to all of the American people I say on
behalf of the President of the United
States
in the Whitehouse coronavirus task force
that because of all that we've done over
the last four months we're ready we're
in a much better place than we were four
months ago or even two months ago part
of our briefing today will focus on the
progress that we have made and our
ability to respond to the outbreaks that
we're seeing occurring in states
particularly across the south I've been
traveling across the country I was
actually in Texas over this past weekend
received a full briefing from Governor
Abbott about their response and I will
be traveling to Arizona tomorrow meeting
with Governor Ducey and I'll be able to
confirm to him that we were informed
today that a team deployed by FEMA of 62
a disaster medical assistance personnel
are on the ground in Arizona we're also
currently processing a request from
Texas and we're in consultation with
other states as you will hear in a
moment with regard to testing with
regard to personal protective equipment
with regard to ventilators with regard
to therapeutic medicines we are in a
strong position all across the affected
areas of the country to meet this moment
but in consultation with the states
we're we're gonna make sure that they
have the reinforcements in health care
workers and and I'm pleased to confirm
today that 62 d-mat or disaster medical
assistant team members have arrived in
Arizona
I'll also be traveling later this week
to the state of Florida
where dr. Burks and I will also receive
a briefing along with secretary a czar
about that state's response at the
present moment all 50 states in the
country are reopening and have done so
in one degree or another since the
beginning of May when we issued our
guidelines to open up America again at
this moment in time because of the
rising cases at least four states have
taken action to close down bars limit
capacity and rest
and and another ten states have slowed
down or postponed certain reopening
efforts and and let me make it very
clear that we fully support the new
guidance that's been issued by the
governor's in these states we truly do
believe that these these prudent
measures and additional guidance and
steps will make it possible for us to
continue to move our nation forward can
you reopen in a safe and responsible way
while putting the health the health of
our citizens first I thought doctor foul
Qi put it well in a recent taskforce
meeting when he said and I think also
testified today that we should not look
at public safety measures as an
impediment to opening up America that
rather we should look at them as the
vehicle to opening up as we see rising
cases and particularly those twelve
states where we have a combination of
rising cases and in positivity the
American people deserve to know that our
best health experts say it's not an
either/or it's not whether we continue
to open up or whether we move in an
opposite direction but rather it's
whether we take these prudent measures
that that will slow the spread and put
the health of our citizens first our
governors in the affected areas and
their public health officials are making
are taking strong action to keep their
states open well while slowing the
spread and and putting the health of
their citizens first and they have our
full support let me say again as I said
at the outset the American people
deserve to know that we're in a much
better place today thanks to the
whole-of-government approach the whole
of America approach the president Trump
initiated at the very outset of the
corona virus pandemic the working in
cooperation with agencies across the
federal government working with the
private sector across this country
we literally have scaled now 33 million
tests have been performed across the
United States and as Admiral Brenner our
will detail momentarily we
we're testing between 500 and 600
thousand Americans every single day with
the capacity to significantly increase
that through the innovation of what is
known as pooling and when it comes to
medical supplies
FEMA has facilitated the delivery of
literally billions of gloves and gowns
and masks and as Admiral pull-up checked
will detail in just a few moments we are
in continuous contact with not just
States but with hospitals in states
across the country and we continue to
receive very strong support reports
about the support they've received in
the supplies that are available to meet
this moment also we're in a much better
place because of the availability of
what's known as therapeutics or
medicines to treat people that have
contracted the corona virus and are
experiencing severe symptoms dr. Steve
Hahn of the FDA is here and he will
speak about the progress that that we
are making whether it be the
availability of REM DES aveer which
we're distributing another tranche this
week the use of blood plasma steroid
treatments and and also we continue to
hear very hopeful signs about the
continuing continuing progress for
developing a vaccine for the American
people and so with that I'm gonna I'm
gonna yield to the team here to give you
updates I'm going to begin with
secretary sr who will update us on our
national response including important
work the CDC did today with regard to
opening up our schools again and and
then Admiral Jarrar will update us on
testing Admiral pull-up check on
supplies dr. Hahn on medicines and then
finally we'll we'll hear from dr. Jerome
Adams the Surgeon General of the United
States who will give counsel to every
American in the States that are impacted
and all across the country about about
best practices so - to every American in
states that are seeing rising cases and
and rising trends in positivity we want
we want to assure you were with you and
we're deploying at the president's
direction the full resources of the
federal
government to meet this moment and
working in strong partnership with your
state and local officials and to every
American we want to assure you that
we're ready more ready than ever before
to meet this coronavirus pandemic
because of the because of the resources
that our president that agencies at the
federal government the steps and
deployed and efforts at state government
and and mostly because of what the
American people have done and
demonstrated that they have the ability
to do I mean the truth is while we we've
made great progress on making
availability testing and supplies and
and medicines we all need to do our part
we know how to slow the spread and the
common-sense measures that that we
outlined in our phased approach to open
up America again the guidelines that
apply to all of the phases are ought to
be embraced by every American wash your
hands
practice good hygiene wear masks wear a
mask when whenever your state and local
authorities say it's appropriate so
where it's always a good idea to wear a
mask when social distancing is not
possible we're all in this together
and we have every confidence that as as
we met the moment before when we saw
this pandemic first strike in the
northwest and then strike so hard around
the Greater New York City area then New
Orleans then Michigan with a
whole-of-government approach a whole of
America approach cooperation the
American people will do what we did
earlier on in this pandemic will slow
the spread and will save lives and with
that a secretary a czar and members the
team will brief and then we'll have time
for questions mr. secretary
well thank you mr. vice president for
honoring HHS in the commissioned Corps
with your presence today and thank you
for your leadership of the presidents
all of America response to kovat 19 I'd
also like to thank Admirals your hua and
Vice Admiral Adams for their service
during this crisis and for their
dedication to strengthening the
commissioned Corps the men and women of
the Commission Corrib in and will
continue to be central to our kovat 19
response and on all six points of our
strategy to defeat the virus
surveillance testing containment health
care capacity vaccines and therapeutics
to every member of the commissioned
Corps who's gone into harm's way in this
crisis who's spent time away from home
and loved ones we are deeply grateful I
want to mention one particular step
forward we took today to help Americans
get back to work and back to school
while protecting us from the virus new
guidance from the CDC as to how higher
education institutions can protect
students and their employees in
particular it offers recommendations for
how and when testing should be used for
students faculty and staff including
both testing for symptomatic individuals
and testing for asymptomatic individuals
who have had possible exposure to the
virus the guidance also notes that in
areas with moderate to substantial
community transmission where resources
allow colleges and universities can work
with local health officials to consider
testing asymptomatic students and staff
who have no known exposure this may make
sense in order to identify outbreaks and
inform control measures and would
especially apply to groups like those
living in congregate housing this
guidance relies on what we've learned
about the virus in recent months in the
very near future we will also be
releasing similar guidance around K
through 12 schools recognizing how
important safe schools are to reopening
our country these are just two examples
of the science-based resources that
we're providing for state and local
health department's and other
institutions as they work with federal
assistance to continue the fight against
the virus and to reopen our country we
need to reopen America we have to get
back to work back to school back to
worship back
health care but we must all play our
individual parts to enable this
reopening we can reverse these outbreaks
and prevent future ones by doing what
the president has called for since the
beginning in his guidance practice
social distancing where facial coverings
where social distancing is not possible
and practice good personal hygiene by
doing so you protect yourself you
protect vulnerable household members but
you also protect the person you may be
standing next to in the grocery line and
you don't know whether they're
vulnerable
you have no way of knowing whether
they're at high risk of severity
hospitalization or fatality you protect
them they're just three simple steps to
keep reopening social distance where
facial coverings when you can't social
distance and practice good personal
hygiene it's all we need to do to keep
reopening we can work go to school go to
worship re-engage with health care if we
all as individuals practice good
responsible behavior to protect each
other and to protect ourselves so thank
you very much for as
Thank You mr. vice president mr.
secretary again you did us incredible
honor by being here and honoring and
appreciating the 6100 women and men of
the commissioned Corps we do say women
and men we are 55 percent female service
in the most diverse within the country
I'm gonna take a few minutes and talk
about testing as both the vice-president
the secretary said we're a world
different than we were in March at that
time in early March we'd only done a few
thousand tests now we're doing five
hundred and fifty six hundred thousand
we've actually gone over six hundred
thousand per day on occasion over 33
million tests and I think all you know
there's some components to this they're
sort of the front end somebody to take
the swab or to supervise you doing that
swab got to have the supplies there you
got to have the machines and you got to
have the laboratory tests so on the
front end way back in March this had to
be done by a practitioner with a very
deep nasopharyngeal swab in full PPE we
could not get to where we are today from
there without a lot of science and a lot
of collaboration from the FDA because
we're able to validate nasal self
swabbing those 41 sites turned into
which you saw today in the press over
600 retail pharmacy sites that have now
been extended for several months
continuing from their first June 30th
closure now at least through August
where they're supervised self swabbing
that has translated into another 1,400
CVS sites so now 2,000 retail pharmacy
sites born from those first 41 in over
1,300 federally qualified health center
sites again most of these focused on the
most underserved communities and
vulnerable communities so we're scaling
that and every week we're getting new
authorizations from the FDA to take it
the next step further and that's home
self swabbing there are some
authorizations that our home self
swabbing and some that are video
assisted so we could eliminate a lot of
the whole front end prop
where we are as I said many times we're
in scaling testing on a routine basis
and I've told you that assuming no
technological innovations we will easily
be at 40 to 50 million tests available
by September that's a very conservative
estimate very conservative estimate
because the industry tells us we'll be
at a much higher place but what are some
of the innovations we're seeing right
now being implemented again under the
guidance of the FDA validated high
quality and that's pooling you've heard
you've heard something about pooling
pooling is very hopeful because it could
combined more than one sample in a
single laboratory assay so imagine this
situation where I wanted to know if all
of you were more potentially negative
and I thought you were probably negative
because you don't have a history you're
not febrile you haven't been in contact
with anyone so you could collect your
own swabs you can put them in tubes and
we can take all of those tubes or at
least ten of them and put them into a
single tube and do that assay if if that
one single assay is negative then you're
all negative if you do it appropriately
so you can leverage two times five times
possibly even up to ten times or even
more this is being done now in many
universities in many commercial
laboratories and we are absolutely
working with everyone in the community
to do this it's not red all the time but
it's right a lot of the time so of those
1820 million tests per month that we'll
probably be doing in July out of those
35 to 50 60 million tests we're doing in
September you can do the math and
multiply at least a portion of those by
two three or even five so that's where
pooling is going to get us the final
thing I would like to say is the red X
program that's the rate the diet the
Diagnostics program at NIH as well as
the biomedical Advanced Research
Development Authority are really making
great inroads to innovation this was
funded to sort of get us to the next
step to provide more rapid tests higher
quantities
test completely different kinds of tests
now again we're not assuming any
breakthrough innovations but there's
gonna be some and I'm very excited about
that
the NIH director Francis Collins the
barter director dr. Gary dis bro and I
work literally on a daily basis to make
sure that the innovations that come on
will be translated immediately to our
public health system so I'm be happy to
take your questions later on today thank
you
well thank amber of Gerar thank you for
your great efforts I know I speak for
people all across this country when I
express how proud we are the
extraordinary progress the way we've
scaled testing across America is
historic when I was tapped to lead the
White House coronavirus task force we
had done less than 8,000 coronavirus
tests and to think that in the
intervening months now 33 million tests
and the ability to scale beyond that
it's a it is a great comfort to the
American people and a great tribute a
great tribute to the public/private
partnership that President Trump forged
early on I think it's also been historic
to see the progress that we've made on
personal protective equipment and
particularly for Americans in in the
four states where 50% of the cases are
occurring or the 12 states where we're
seeing a combination of rising cases in
positivity we want the American people
to know that the personal protective
equipment for our health care providers
is also at a historic level and I've
asked Admiral John Paul of check to come
and to articulate where we stand today
with the hospitals and health care
facilities in the impacted areas and in
our ongoing effort to ensure that the
extraordinary doctors and nurses and
health care workers that are at this
very hour ministering to Americans
struggling with the coronavirus I have
the masks the gowns the gloves the
ventilators and all the personal
protective equipment they need to render
that care but Admiral object
Thank You mr. vice president the back in
March mid-march when I was moved for the
Pentagon to to FEMA the president gave
me one task provide our health care
workers the supplies they need what they
need when they need it and I'm gonna
give you a short update today and I
think the theme is we have more so from
from that time in March
I mean March until now we are in a
fundamentally better position I'm gonna
go through some details that makes me
that that confident and personally those
that personally know me I'm a
glass-half-full type of person and so
for these these details I find very
encouraging as we over the last few
weeks tried to ascertain how well States
and hospital networks are preparing in
preparing for the summer into the fall
we we held a round of state calls with
every state emergency manager in every
state health official facilitated by the
FEMA Regional Administrator so we went
through every region in every state and
I had a discussion about what we were
doing for the national stockpile and
what they were doing for their states
that call led me to believe that 65 to
70 percent of the states have at least
30 days of supply on hand if not 60
there are many states that have more
than 60 that have targets of 90 and
looking to achieve that those state
calls have confident of the numbers that
we're putting into our modernized
national stockpile here in recent weeks
with the uptick in cases where dr. Burks
is highlighted down to the county level
my team has called
those hospitals and I am here to provide
a synopsis of that we've talked to
hospitals in Dallas Phoenix
Houston and and on down the line many of
them are reporting thirty to forty days
of supply of on hand now there are some
sporadic shortages but mostly in the
size of size of masks could I have more
small masks so we took that information
and I talked to 3m today as a matter of
fact and they've already changed based
on discussions with my team they've
already changed their production to
produce more small and extra small mass
so essentially almost an even split 40
45 50 percent more small and to then to
the rest to normal supplies so states
are saying they have supplies hospitals
in areas where there are outbreaks or
having more supplies another data tool
the National Health Safety Network where
at CDC run Network where hospitals
report days of supplies on hand across
the nation those supplies back in March
there were many hospitals that were
saying that they had less than three
days now folks have multiple weeks the
majority of hospitals so we are we are
fundamentally in a different place one
of the things we did was we assembled
all of the business system data for the
medical supply chain for the commercial
medical supply chain I have that
resident at FEMA and I can see the
demand from hospitals and the supply to
them and those numbers are coming
together where supply is getting much
closer to met to demand all at the same
time that states are stockpiling
municipalities are stockpiling hospitals
are stockpiling and the federal
government
the Health and Human Services strategic
national stockpile is being being
replenished so let me let me shift
topics to the nursing home project just
real quick we're on our second round in
the nursing home project
you know those give a little bit more
than a week's worth of supply each each
round has a you know almost two million
I set survived production 14 million
masks 63 million gowns gloves and 13
million gowns to get to the 15,000 plus
nursing homes we're 60% through this
second round and 45% have been delivered
and finally let me just touch on
ventilators so back in March this
national stockpile had approximately
19,000 Bellairs today ready for
deployment
we have 48,000 by next week if the
production schedules hold
we'll have 55,000 so we are we are in a
fundamentally different place for
supplies then then we are pinning your
questions later mr. president it's on
and in one other area where we've made
great strides and we hope and pray to
make good strides in the months ahead
has been in the area of therapeutics and
in the headlong pursuit of vaccines when
we see the extraordinary decline in
fatalities over the last two months it
is attribute first to our health care
workers to all that they've done but
it's also a tribute to the availability
of of what are known as therapeutics and
medicines like REM disappear the new
steroid treatment that you all have
heard about the availability of plasma
treatments and and I wanted dr. Steve
Hahn of the FDA to update us on on the
medicines as well as where we stand on
vaccine
dr. hunt thank you Thank You mr. vice
president president Trump asked the FDA
early on the Cova 19 pandemic to reduce
any unnecessary regulatory barriers to
get medical products into the hands of
Americans and FDA created an emergency
review and development program for
therapies called the corona virus
treatment acceleration program and we
have supported that program since that
time and it continues to this day
I'd like to first start by telling you
that the pipeline of therapeutics
treatments that we see across this
country the great academics researchers
private sector that pipeline is very
robust currently currently as a recent
count FDA is monitoring more than 144
active trials of therapeutic agents for
kovin 19 and another 457 development
programs for therapeutic agents is in
the pipeline so we're in a vastly
different place than we were three
months ago two months ago the nation's
work is paying off as we saw the
positive results of the recent National
Institutes of Allergy and Infectious
Disease trial of rim DES aveer in
certain hospitalized patients with a
significant 30% reduction in the length
of hospital stay for severe kovat 19
patients we also recently updated the
clinical guidelines for the treatment of
kovat 19 disease with the addition of
dexamethasone and other corticosteroids
with a trial that reported a 30%
reduction in mortality and severely ill
patients those two therapies alone will
have a significant impact on the natural
history in the course of this disease
and provides great hope for those who
get sick with this and are hospitalized
but our work isn't done more is in the
pipeline as I mentioned over 25,000
patients in the United States have been
treated on our expanded access
convalescent plasma program just as a
reminder that's where we take antibodies
the antibodies that are naturally
developed by someone who has gotten the
Cova 19 virus and then has recovered and
then we administer that to someone who's
sick with kovin
19 this has worked in other diseases in
the past we have some preliminary safety
data in over 20,000 patients it shows
that this therapy is safe and we're
currently evaluating the efficacy of
this the effectiveness of this program
we had great hope for that now that
information will tell us a lot about if
a person develops antibodies how
protective are those antibodies what
level do you need and it also gives us
information for the next set of
therapeutics that are coming down the
pike already in clinical trials we have
a number of agents called monoclonal
antibodies which are synthetic forms of
antibodies so genetically engineered
antibodies that can then be given again
these have been used in other infectious
diseases and we have hoped that they
would also work in these disease in
kovat 19 and we expect the readout of
those trials over the next several
months possibly late summer and early
fall so I just want to switch gears to
to talk about vaccines under the
leadership of secretary aids are an
operation warp-speed we have seen the
sponsorship of a number of different
vaccines but we know that vaccines are
being developed around the world
and FDA has received applications from
double-digit number of sponsors
regarding vaccines for vaccines have
been approved from moving into clinical
trials that is authorized to go into
clinical trials so we can get the data
on those vaccines and another six are in
the pipeline for us to review we've seen
recent reports of interesting and I
think positive data regarding the
immunogenicity that is how well these
vaccines stimulate an immune and immune
response in people and also regarding
their safety more work needs to be done
but I think we've seen some positive
results of the date and obviously we
need to make sure that those studies
mature so that we can have the data we
need now FDA recognizes the need and
urgent need to develop a safe and
effective vaccine for koban 19 and we've
been working collaboratively with all
industry and all of our partners in
academia as well as in government on
that today we took additional action to
facilitate the timely development of
safe and effective vaccines to prevent
Kovan 19 by providing new guidance with
recommendations for those developing
Cova 19
scenes and the goal of this guidance is
to assist in the clinical development
and ultimately hopefully the licensure
of a vaccine for the Prevention of kovat
19 now it's very important to have this
guidance because it provides regulatory
transparency and clarity to the
developers what is FDA expecting to see
in terms of data and science in the
context of clinical trials so that we
can make the absolute best decision for
the American people
now while the FDA is committed to
expediting this work we will not cut
corners in order to approve a vaccine
and we will make clear through this
guidance what data are needed to meet
our regulatory standards I remain
cautiously optimistic about our timeline
with respect to vaccines we will see
what the data show but clearly from a
therapeutics point of view there are
more tools in the toolbox for the great
providers of this country to treat
patients with covin 19 and then finally
I'd like to add to what the vice
president said and that is mask-wearing
social distancing hand hygiene and other
forms of hygiene this is how we're going
to keep America open again I've heard
from colleagues around the country my
former colleagues in in cancer care from
friends and families nobody wants to
shut down again our way of keeping open
is with these public health measures
thank you very much and as you can see
we're in a much better place whether it
be testing whether it be personal
protective equipment whether it be
ventilators or whether it be the
availability of medicines that are
speeding relief to Americans struggling
with coronavirus and I and I promise you
that as the president has director from
the very beginning we're going to
continue to bring the full resources of
the federal government to bear in
support of governor's and states that
are being impacted and by the latest
outbreak of the corona virus but as we
said at the beginning we're all in this
together and we all have a role to play
and so I wanted to ask the Surgeon
General to bring a few remarks about
about how every American can play their
part to slow the spread to put into
practice the
the kind of personal habits that will
ensure not just that they protect their
own health or the health of a family
member or friend but most especially as
has been said already we see that
roughly half of the new cases in Texas
in Florida we are told are among
Americans under the age of 35 for whom
the the threat of serious outcomes from
the corona viruses fairly low but it's
not just about protecting yourself as a
young person it's about making sure that
anyone who is vulnerable to a serious
outcome with the corona virus is
protected no one of any age would ever
want to inadvertently expose a mother a
father or grandmother or grandfather and
what the Surgeon General share with us
are the kind of practices
that'll make it possible for all of us
to do our part to slow the spread to
heal our land even as we continue to
open up America again good evening
everyone Thank You mr. vice-president
for being here at Public Health Service
commissioned Corps headquarters today we
very much appreciate it and I just want
to start off by saying that we
absolutely cannot afford to lose focus
on the disproportionate impact that
covin 19 has had on vulnerable
communities particularly communities of
color compared to whites American
Indians and Alaskan Natives are
hospitalized at five times the rate
black Americans hospitalized at four and
a half times the rate Hispanics three
and a half times the rate the fact is
this virus is exploiting and
exacerbating pre-existing health
disparities in these disparate outcomes
and inequitable opportunities for health
a part of the anger the frustration and
the fear that we're seeing manifest in
protests around the country the fact is
social justice and social injustice
often reveals itself through health
inequities in the administration in my
office are using our unique levels
including the Public Health Service
commissioned Corps to ensure that every
American has the opportunity to be
healthy at Secretary Ahlers direction
we've been working at HHS to address
these disparities long before the
but in response to the pandemic we've
taken a number of additional immediate
actions and as we're talking about both
the burden of disease and our
communities but the resources that are
now available to folks to help respond I
want to quickly run down some of these
efforts
Admiral Joe hua has led our increase in
community-based testing over 600 sites
70% of them are in communities that have
a high social vulnerability index which
means they're disproportionately serving
people of color CDC now requires all
testing data reported by States include
information on race ethnicity and zip
code this mandate will help us better
understand who is most affected and how
to target interventions on the hardest
hit communities HHS recently allocated
15 billion dollars to Medicaid providers
and 10 billion to safety net hospitals
which serve large numbers of our most
vulnerable Americans the
administration's also invested critical
resources in community health centers
which I often say our best-kept secrets
ensuring that 28 million people living
in medically underserved areas have
access to care and testing that they
need we don't want our federally
qualified and community health centers
to be secrets to the people who most can
benefit from the care that they receive
there i'm secretary ather and i want to
thank you for this sir has instructed my
office to expedite calls to action on
hypertension which is the number one
risk factor for Kovach complications and
maternal mortality both of which
disproportionately impact people of
color and i am very worried about infant
mortality and maternal mortality going
up in the midst of Kovan because women
are scared to go out and get care we
need to safely reopen so that people the
care that they need
beyond Ovid last week you heard Admiral
jawoll announced that Morehouse School
of Medicine was awarded 40 million
dollars as part of a cooperative
agreement with the office of minority
health this effort will be a major leap
forward and help us achieve our goal of
delivering important Ovid 19 updates and
information in ways and through channels
that best reach minority communities and
speaking of reaching minority
communities we're really digging in to
engagement with other folks so I had a
phone call last week with over a hundred
different organizations that that are
embedded in communities Jesse Jackson's
Rainbow PUSH coalition the National
Hispanic Medical Association the
National Association of black nurses and
over a hundred other organizations were
on the phone call this administration
HHS were committed to outreach to make
sure we can get the information to the
people who most need the benefit from it
and to the point of the VP's visit here
today one of the reasons I'm proud to be
a leader in the Public Health Service
commissioned Corps is our mission to
serve the underserved having a Ready
Reserve which is the announcement that
we made earlier today will augment our
efforts to eliminate health disparities
and ensure everyone has the best chance
at a long and healthy life one of eight
uniformed services the Public Health
Service is the only one dedicated solely
to protecting and promoting America's
public health by a number of metrics we
are the most diverse uniformed service
over 50 percent of our officers are
female and only 40 percent identify as
white and non-hispanic we provide
essential health services where most
others do not go dare not go in some
cases to provide care for vulnerable and
underserved populations the bulk of our
officers are at Indian Health Service
Health Services facilities and we have a
large number of officers in the Bureau
of Prisons to communities that have been
particularly hard-hit bykova 19 we serve
on the front line of public health
emergencies my first deployment was to
Puerto Rico and the US Virgin Islands
after three category 5 hurricanes in a
row hit those unfortunate territories we
respond quickly to natural disasters
disease outbreaks and global public
health emergencies like Ebola as well as
serve on humanitarian missions we also
advance innovation in science and work
at the forefront of medical challenges
like kovat 19 cancer in the opioid
crisis providing new treatments and
cures which leads me to my finish we are
in a much better place to treat Kovan
than what we were two months ago four
months ago even just a few weeks ago you
heard Admiral of Czech talk about how we
are better supplied than what we were
does it mean that it's mission
accomplished but we are in a much better
place now with PPE and with other
supplies
with steroids room desapear in
convalescent plasma if you get kovat 19
we are in a much better position to get
you out of the hospital safely but
public health is all about prevention
and I'm a leader in the Public Health
Service Corps so I want to talk about
prevention my Surgeon General's
prescription which I first announced
you-all way back in march three things
number one know your risk are you at
high risk are you at low risk are you at
intermediate risk for kovat 19 number
two know your circumstances are you in a
community where rates are going up are
you in a community where rates are going
down are you going to a place where you
can take precautions like being outside
and social distancing and number three
know how to stay safe and that includes
everything from making sure we're taking
basic precautions to staying home if
you're at high risk or you're going to a
high risk place the fact is we're seeing
an increase in cases and an increase in
hospitalizations in those under 40 so we
need everyone to follow our preventive
guidelines stay home if you're sick
stay home if you're vulnerable and again
we know people are more vulnerable as
they get older but they're also
vulnerable if they have hypertension
diabetes and obesity wash your hands or
use hand sanitizer frequently went out
maintained six feet of distance between
you and others when you're out and
please please please wear a face
covering when you go out in public it is
not an inconvenience
it's not a suppression of your freedom
it actually is a vehicle to achieve our
goals it adds to your convenience in
your freedom because it allows us to
open up more places and it allows those
places to stay open when you do not wear
your face covering we end up in a
situation where you see higher rates of
disease spread and you end up having to
close places this mask this face
covering actually is an instrument of
freedom for Americans if we
use it young people I just want to close
by by asking you two to work with us
please work with us because I know that
many of you feel like you're not at risk
or you're not as high of a risk but we
need all of you to help protect the most
vulnerable but also to protect
yourselves and to give you more options
if you want the return of college
football this year wear a face covering
if you want a chance to prom next spring
wear a face covering I had a interview
earlier with a North Carolina radio
station if you want to see North
Carolina beat Duke in person this year
wear a face covering and I grew up in
Maryland and in Indiana so sorry Duke
but I as long as somebody beats you I'm
okay with that if you want to go on
spring break next March next April wear
a face covering I want you all to
understand that this is not meant to be
pessimistic I am actually confident
based on the data we've seen around the
country and around the world that if we
do the right things we actually can
reopen and stay open kovat time is a
long time in just a few weeks we can
drastically see things go in the wrong
direction but we also can drastically
see things improve if you all will
commit to wearing these face coverings
in taking basic public health
precautions as the nation's doctor as
America's doctor I want you to know I
have every confidence that we can very
quickly see these new case counts go
down and we can reopen we can get back
to school to work to worship and to
college football but we've all got to do
our part it's up to you America if you
join in and we all do our part we all
win thank you
Thank You dr. Adams thank you so much
we've got time for a few questions great
we've heard a lot about masks today
we've seen cases rising is there any
consideration for making masks mandatory
or penalizing states that aren't
following the CDC guidelines properly
well I think the the success that we
have had from early in the corona virus
is we have followed the model that that
we describe from early on which was to
have a national response that was
federally supported state managed and
locally executed make sure the people on
the ground delivering health care
services the people most impacted by the
disease had what they need that states
would manage the unique circumstances
and that we would marshal the resources
of the federal government and the
private economy to support that and and
we'll continue to use that model
respecting the decisions that governor's
are making there have been states that
have delegated authority to local
communities with regard to facial
coverings and we support those decisions
by governor's but as you can see there's
12 states that we're watching very
carefully now that have both rising
cases and rising positivity there's four
states where 50% of all the new cases
are happening and so what we want to do
is make sure that that the governor's
the health officials in those states
have the ability to respond in the ways
that are most effective there and and
and that's been a key to our success
thus far making sure as this pandemic
has made its way first in the northwest
then in the Northeast then New Orleans
Michigan other parts of the country
we've made sure that the governor's and
health officials had what they need when
they needed it and we've expressed and
continue to express our full support for
the measures and decisions that they've
made so go right ahead
I'd love to ask secretary is our button
about schools but first I wanted to ask
you you know dr. Baptiste said today
it's preface this I think everyone
realizes that it weren't a better
position now than what this started no
much better place but dr. factory said
today quote we're going in the wrong
direction I'm sure that you've seen all
of those charts you know you look at all
of these wealthy countries you see these
these curves and it goes up and it goes
down and then you look at the u.s. curve
and it kind of started to go down and
now it's going back up well when you
think about the corona virus pandemic
and the way it's impacted the United
States we first observed the case
emerging in Seattle and then in the
Northeast then in New Orleans than in
Michigan and in each individual area I
had its own impact and by by instituting
the guidance and the measures that we
instituted supporting governor's we were
able to flatten the curve in each of
those areas and we're confident that we
will be able with the cooperation of the
American people and the efforts that are
taking place in states across the
country that that will be able to slow
the spread and flatten the curve in the
south as well but I think what's what's
important to understand is that while in
in these outbreaks there we've seen some
instances of agricultural workers we've
seen some instances of discrete
populations that that according to what
they tell us out of Florida and Texas is
roughly half of those people that are
testing positive AR AR
and cousin
success that we've had with testing
we've been able to test people all
across this country who are asymptomatic
it you know I think it it's it's worth
knowing that that early in this process
we focus testing exclusively on people
that were vulnerable or where health
care workers or people that had symptoms
now we literally test anyone who comes
to a testing site or comes to their
local pharmacy
and and it's it's in arguable that some
measure of the new cases that we see are
a result of the fact that we're testing
500 to 600 thousand Americans a day that
being said I think the secretary made
this point that it who's contracted the
corona virus to be able to able to
communities to protect the most
vulnerable but but when you look at the
extraordinary success the United States
has had the historic success we've had
in testing it's you do well to
understand that that's contributed in
part we were talking in the number of
cases frankly until several weeks ago
but because hope of our testing we were
able to see this not only state
government's efforts federal resources
but the cooperation of the American
people
and and it gives us great confidence
that we'll be able as we did before in
other parts of the country that we'll be
able to slow the spread and flatten the
curve again mr. secretary
go back to work if you are a working
parent if your kid does not in school
that is pretty much an impossibility and
so as we're starting to hear in
different schools presenting their plans
from the fall it sounds like there'll be
a lot of stagger schedules maybe kids
will go to school certain hours they
might go to school every second day what
is the federal government doing to help
schools to help current investing and
hiring more teachers investing in
building new school classrooms
developing programs for parents well so
what we're what we're doing is providing
guidance out of CDC to make sure that
our schools can have the best
information possible about how they
could bring kids back safely so for
instance you don't need to you don't
need to have everyone in auditoriums you
can have some of those congregate
settings you would not you would avoid
you might have fewer kids in each
classroom have the desks be socially
distance within the classrooms instead
of having the kids eating in a cafeteria
have them eating at their desks so there
steps that we can take that are very
consistent with what we've talked about
here social distancing facial coverings
when you can't social distance of course
ensuring good personal hygiene these are
the kinds of it's just very common-sense
steps and then on top of that we're
gonna want to make sure we have very
robust surveillance systems at our
schools and our higher education as well
as our K through 12 so that we have
early early spotting if we're seeing any
emergence of disease in these
institutions and so that's part of what
Admiral 0aa has been working on is
really enhancing these surveillance
systems and testing systems for instance
the pooling that he spoke about that can
allow us to leverage very large-scale
surveillance types screening there with
pooling with follow-up in the event of
any positive cases in a large group of
people
the resources so that if you're a school
district that already has crowded
classrooms you don't have the space for
kids to be able to spread out in their
classroom what I defer to the Secretary
of Education on that one but we'll
provide the health support for them and
dr. Redfield reported the task force
today that we published today guidance
for higher education colleges and
universities as well as K through 12 and
at the present time 47 states have
already issued guidance about reopening
their schools and I can tell you that
President Trump and I on our entire
administration are absolutely committed
to getting our kids back to school this
fall go back to school we do well first
and foremost I hope what you heard today
is we're ready and we're more prepared
than ever before and I want the people
particularly in the 12 states that we
see rising cases and rising positivity
to know that we're with them and we're
going to make sure that we we expand
testing working with their governors and
health officials to identify people in
the communities that have contracted the
disease including people that have no
symptoms and we're going to make sure
and extend and distribute personal
protective equipment although you heard
from a Mapple up check that hospitals in
all the affected areas have abundant
supplies of personal protective
equipment we're going to make sure that
ventilators and other critical medical
apparatus are available and this week
we're distributing the last tranche of
REM des aveer to all 50 states to make
sure that that medicine is available my
so my answer is we're ready we're ready
to respond and we are responding all
across the country working with the
governor's
across the country but to answer the the
the the core of your question you know
we we literally saw cases declining
precipitously because of what the
American people had done there was a
there was some discussion about the fact
that that that this was a result of
states reopening but Texas and Florida
and other states involved here reopened
very early in May they implemented the
phased guidelines that we publish to
open up America again and through the
course of the entire month of May and
into early June their cases were low and
steady and their positivity rates were
rising but something changed about two
weeks ago and because of the
extraordinary capacity we have for
testing we were able to observe that to
work with governors and what we're doing
now is responding inviting information
with governor's providing the support
decisions in their states that have our
full support that we believe will as as
those measures did before that will have
the effect as the American people put
all these principles into practice that
will have the effect of slowing the
spread and flattening the curve but
we're we're leaning into this effort and
will continue to lean into it
but it seems that as July 4th is coming
around and Americans all over the
country there's a going well the
president's wore the masks in public SMI
and you've heard a strong encouragement
about mask wearing but let me let me say
we believe that that Americans should
wear a mask whenever state and local
authorities indicate and that it's
appropriate or whenever social
distancing is not possible and will
continue to convey that message but you
know this is a the American people have
already demonstrated in the way that we
saw extraordinary progress in the
Greater New York City area the
incredible progress in the Greater New
Orleans area in Detroit and other places
we know that when the American people
are equipped with knowledge about how
they can play a role to protect their
family members and neighbors and
particularly those most vulnerable then
the American people will will put those
into practice but we're we're going to
continue to respect the right of every
American but encourage them to listen to
state and local authorities the guidance
that they have but we honestly we we
honestly couldn't be more inspired by
what we've been able to do so far and as
we see in these 12 states that have rise
in cases in rising positivity where we
remain confident confident not only in
the resources that we're able to bring
to bear because of the whole of
government the whole of America approach
the president Trump initiated but we're
confident that that the American people
will respond and they'll put
health of their families and neighbors
first even as we continue to open up
America you say we're in a better place
now than we were two and four months ago
and in many states that that it does
back this up that said are you and the
task force members content with the
length of time it's taken to get us to
this point well I couldn't be more proud
of what the American people have done in
the course of this coronavirus pandemic
beginning with the President of the
United States we didn't have a single
case of person-to-person transmission of
the corona virus when President Trump
suspended all travel from China at the
end of January and stood up the White
House coronavirus task force he
initiated efforts that that would set
into motion at the FDA the development
of a vaccine that was able to go to its
first clinical trial in record time of
62 days he pulled he initiated through
the task force bringing together private
sector firms literally an effort to
reinvent clinical testing in the United
States of America
we stood up not just an air bridge but
whatever full of Jack calls a control
tower where we we marshal all the
resources of the private sector and and
we were able to direct billions of
personal protective equipment masks and
gloves and gowns to the point of the
need which you've heard many times
throughout our our response has been
that at the president's direction we
made sure that states had what they need
when they needed it it's it it defined
our approach to this pandemic as it as
it had it's heartbreaking impact in New
York State and in New Jersey and
Connecticut and the environs and and and
it's that approach focusing particularly
on those 12 states today
that that we see rising cases and
positivity that that will continue to
drive forward to meet this moment but
I'm very proud of the partnership we've
had with governor's around the country
I'm proud of the of the whole of
government approach president Trump
initiated but be honest with you I'm
just most proud of the American people
of the resilience the compassion the
cooperation and the faith that I've seen
all across this country and it gives me
great confidence as we go forward that
we see this new outbreak in states
across the South that once again our
health care workers our partners at the
state level this great team at the
federal level and the American people
are going to meet this moment and we're
going to slow the spread we're gonna
flatten the curve and we're gonna save
lives thank you all very much
don't wave the white flag